I got into some voice acting work where
I worked for a cult here in Japan when
you hear their voices you have to imbue
that in English I had to feel nine
different voices so I went full Dynasty
Warriors like three with it I was like
the heavens
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast I'm
Joey and I'm with the boys as per usual
and with me I have a guest introduce
yourself
my name is Peter and I am a former
English teacher after 10 years of
suffering from my child and I'm here to
educate you guys on my final lesson
about what it's like the final lesson
this is it my lasting memories are being
put to this recording of teaching
English in Japan and all the shame that
comes with it but you're not just a
former English teacher in Japan you're
also a full-time twitch streamer on you
missed a Premiere too well I mean there
are a lot of people who can claim to be
full-time twitch
and I I think that when I first started
teaching that teaching is considered
kind of the great shame of of jobs in
Japan
[Music]
and then I became a twitch stream and I
realized no there's lower so I am okay
but no I didn't got him yeah it's true
um but no teaching is an interesting
profession right of course in most
societies it's highly respected and then
you take one look at someone like me and
you realize maybe not but the thing is
is I think a lot of people want to come
to Japan and they need an opportunity to
do so yeah and imagine
for example
you have no marketable skills or a
theater degree or really selling
yourself
but if you did have those things but you
have a bachelor's well then you've got
an opportunity to come to be a teacher
that's just Asia right yeah it's it's
just like it was the same thing in
Thailand where you could like you could
be the most under like all you need is a
bachelor's either you can get like any
job you wanted and it could be and it
could be any battery yeah yeah well
trust me I know like in America I had a
theater degree right which is about it's
really good for waiting tables like
you're a greater it's listen to it as
well and that's um but when you come to
Japan and you do teach I think the expat
Community or the other people who are in
Japan look you know they look down upon
it pretty heavily okay so that's one
thing I've wanted to ask straight up all
right because like I think there's a lot
of people who watch Trash taste and just
like Japan content in General right so
obviously they're like I want to be able
to go to Japan and when they go do their
research they realize okay the easiest
way is to become an English teacher in
Japan right like that's like the easiest
like Gateway method right but like I
think I think the general consensus of
like English teachers in Japan being
like as you put a like a shameful like
positional I guess history I don't I
don't know I personally haven't heard
much about that so obviously you have
the experience of being in that position
none of us do yeah because why do you
think that is the case yeah because uh I
think we've met like a few English
teachers yeah uh who have lived in Japan
but I think you have one of the most
interesting stories out of like most out
of like a lot of people we've met and
also
um you have like I like a lot of people
we've brought on who is who have also
lived in Japan you've had the true expat
experience yeah for sure because you've
lived in Japan for how long now almost
uh 11 years or 12 years now well there's
something like I get it time loses
meaning yeah at a certain point it came
I came here right after the tohoku
earthquake of 2011. okay so about two
weeks that was a while ago but yeah a
while ago it was a long time I think
though to answer your question about why
it's kind of disrespected and I do want
to be clear as much as I'm joking around
teaching can be a good profession here
yeah but the reason it's looked down
upon is we have to deconstruct like what
is a teacher and what is an English
teacher as a foreigner okay you're not
going to be you know reading Socrates
and explaining all of these cool
Shakespearean stories you are hired as
an Entertainer and or clown
this is you are the Court Jester you
have to imagine you're you're not in a
college setting right right you're
teaching potentially kids who are
anywhere from the ages of zero all the
way through high school and if you're in
elementary school or junior high or
especially you know uh the kind of a
Kiowa special
and be ready to sing some songs right
create some ridiculous lessons yeah to
make English fun and interactive okay so
I've I've uh you know I've heard about
being an English teacher in Japan and a
lot of like other Asian countries but
what is that actually entail what is
what responsibilities are on you and how
much do you have to plan how much it's
different based on what school and what
yeah yeah but what's like the typical
like step-by-step process as a full-time
is there a typical yeah let's go with
like the three different scenarios I
think this will help kind of simplify it
sure let's start with the akaiwa okay
which uh a lot of people who did not get
into a school teach at an ikawa yeah
those are lessons that students come to
anywhere from like two years old up to
maybe Elementary School those are
usually planned out for you or you have
some sort of reference from a book that
some other expat wrote in 19 77 and
you're like all right so we're going to
teach colors today and it can be pretty
brutal like a normal lesson would be
something like this and this is why I
highly recommend you think very hard
about being a teacher you walk into the
classroom and there's about 13 kids
screaming crying sneezing puking
whatever and they're all [__]
they're all just playing with toys and
stuff you give them like five or six
minutes of toy time and this is the
hardest part A lot of the times this is
one of the first times that parents are
leaving their kids alone right so and we
encourage them you tape up all the walls
and you say like just don't look through
the window and the doors don't be
visible because when the door shuts and
I start we need them to just be
distracted and not think where's my mom
and where are you right yeah yeah that
never works
um like zero percent so you'll close the
door and you'll be like all right and
there's like songs you go like
God you're gonna give me PTSD you say
like I want to hear the song you're
lucky I can't stand up and do the full
performance maybe clean up clean up
everybody everywhere clean up clean up
everybody do your share so you have to
so you're about to say everyone do your
[__] yeah yeah everyone clean up your
[__] and stuff yeah yeah that and then
they realize
my parents aren't here and the Water
Works begin it doesn't matter if it's
the first lesson or the 10th this is
something that you have to Grapple with
sure you bought your you know strawberry
Frappuccino with the three dollars that
you've made this year teaching and
you're just like I wish this was
alcoholic and then it's just you got to
do this every single day right five or
six days a week
um in perpetuity until you can escape
that job so this is obviously this is
yeah so this is obviously like targeted
towards you know like what average age I
would say anywhere from uh two all the
way until early middle school and the
middle schoolers are a bit the classes
are smaller it's a bit more personal you
can just say like what are you studying
in in school today let me help you so
those are kind of fun but anywhere in
the
oh man it is it is not but it can be
rewarding of course I'm saying that
because I had two or three good memories
but it is fun to see kids and you help
them learn like what does the color blue
look like in English all right so what
are the other you said that was the
first that's the first one then the next
is elementary school yeah so now you
have to start wearing the suit and you
have to start going to school and
sitting with the morning meetings with
the teachers and there's a lot of
differences from like America like as a
teacher you'd walk up to the the
principal and you'd say like
and he'd be like and then you'd go sit
down and then now you're now you're kind
of in this world where you have an
abundance of free time and you have no
idea how to spend it because you don't
have any money and you you can study
Japanese or you could you know look busy
on the computer but then the classes you
have anywhere from three to five a day
and it's like talking about the weather
or you go in there and tell them about
you know numb numbers or emotions and
then you repeat this for 65 years and
then uh but then the final one is you
get into Junior and High School junior
high school and high school yeah yeah
those are considered I would say the
best positions especially High School
finally the kids have an opportunity to
start explaining you know their
experiences and their they can actually
talk to you yeah let's not jump the gun
some can yes some some can talk to you
yeah but at least you can kind of
extract some
some information that's not you know
what train do you like it's Dr yellow
the shinkansen wow that's amazing or
your favorite color is blue okay and how
old are you I'm seven thank you you know
those are the basics but then in high
school you really get an opportunity
like you said to have conversations if
they choose to yeah if they choose to or
if they can or if they mostly if they
choose to yeah right yeah so so going
back even all the way before this so
what made you want to move Japan in the
first place because I like I assume you
discovered teaching English because that
was one of the most prevalent ways to
like get to move to Japan right it was
um well for me I have a very unique
history I guess it's very unusual when I
was 19 I was in college right I had to
think about that yeah and I was taking a
Japanese lesson because I just had seen
some Japanese movies I thought were cool
and I was like oh you know that sounds
cool Battle Royale was still really
popular and yeah Kira Kosovo films my
buddies and of course video games
um so I took this Japanese class and I
was completely failing it I'm so bad
it's a theme throughout my language but
uh they said the the teacher said hey we
need somebody to be a host family
because this person lost their original
host family because of a disagreement or
something right and I was thinking damn
that would be so sick I could like play
Street Fighter with this dude and we
could hang out all the time and I could
learn Japanese and I was like I'll do
that that sounds cool and it ended up
being a girl who lived it with my mother
and I for like two or three years okay
and whoa and I had in three years well
we got that's long for our host family
right yeah yeah like usually they don't
lost it's like maybe three to six months
like a week or something a week no no I
think on average it's like maybe three
months I guess from that distance I did
it with like Irish kids and that was we
did that for like a week and that was
too much
I did not get along well with my Irish
Council yeah because uh Sydney did the
same thing as well she had a she had a
she had the choice uh between uh her
parents wanted to uh become a host
family for someone abroad and Sydney was
going through a wee place here she was
like pick someone Japanese
yes
it's a Japanese one please well I'm
thankful that she didn't have a catalog
or I would have never come to Japan
because I don't think she would have
chose me but my mom was you know my my
sister had just moved out and so it was
kind of cool because I was living in the
basement like any normal American Boy
and of course and then she took like my
sister's old room upstairs and so we I
think it was a bit longer even when I
went to college in a different city she
stayed at the house and stuff wow but
she said you know your family's been so
kind to to me why don't I introduce you
to my family and you visit Japan so I
was like 20 21 and she lived in Yokohama
which is a really nice place to visit
and I I loved it man it was such a
transformative part of my life yeah
where I was like studying acting and I
could read the tea leaves so to speak I
was like what year was this song this
was
1964 no I'm getting out no this was 2004
or 2000 and uh five almost ten this was
so difficult well yes it was that was
when Akihabara was still the electricity
yeah what are you talking about yeah
because when I went to Akihabara it was
insane when I was growing up Akihabara
was a place of Legend every video game
magazines that egm or game players or
PSM tips and tricks they would have a
correspondent from Akihabara talking
about the sites and the games and the
arcades this is so cool it was there was
like three made cafes as opposed to now
where there's 300 men yeah you went
there and it was the HobbyTown so anyway
I had a great experience and I said you
know if acting doesn't work out
I will I will come to Japan someday
again so I visited two more times and
then at 26 I finally got my college
degree a little later than some would
say
um but I I made the move and that's
where I started and he got that which on
the west coast of Japan that's why I was
interested in coming for sure okay so
did you go through the jet program like
everyone else I applied and and that
sounds lame I uh I meant I made it to
the interview phase but I graduated in
Winter as opposed to like spring or
summer like most students yeah and their
interviews are in like late fall so they
said you've made it to the interview
phase but it would take about nine more
months to have oh [__] so I was like
okay I'll put that in my back pocket but
I'll check out like newsletters or
online sources and if I can find a
opportunity we'll see how it works and
right mine was marketed as beautiful
beach town in the western coast of Japan
and I was like I was like let's [__]
go really where what's
we don't know yet I think it may have
not even been a real company but uh
actually you arrived it was crazy right
well man it was such a mess so you know
I got hired the day before the
earthquake oh [__] and so then the plane
and the moving was pretty rapid from
there and so I was trying to contact
this Source but not be because they were
in um it was like kind of it was an
ibadaki was where their head office was
which was kind of close enough to the
earthquake yeah right and I was
messaging him I was like ah
do I how do I do I have a job but don't
answer me unless it's you can or yeah
you know
yeah
and he was like yes come to Japan and I
was like I don't have a Visa or anything
he's like we'll sort it later and I was
like
so when I got there I was on a tourist
visa and I showed up and I took a bus by
myself to ibadaki and it was still
struggling from the earthquake and we
went into basically a basement and there
was still manila folders and and files
all over the floor and the guy was just
you know the the definition of an expat
who has been in the teaching game too
long he was just like okay everyone uh
you're you're going to uh and I was like
nigata and he's like uh yeah and I was
like okay sure and we had a two-day trip
we had two days of training
um most of it was centered around this
is a sad thing it was uh don't be
inappropriate to the children which is
and I was like yeah I kind of figured
that part out you're gonna tell me bro
well that was like it was like seven of
the eight hours like was examples of
what not to do like for example okay
don't show pornography that's I was like
wow thank you for telling me I had that
one on my bingo yeah well the Italian
Senate could never [__] yeah all right
I guess you're out of there now I was
like well three terabytes gone
the next one may surprise you you're not
supposed to date students wow
and I was sitting there thinking
what have I done just another guy
let's show you like a safety video for
this be like there was no there was
actually limited electricity even
because there was they were doing like
energy but I was thinking like and I did
ask I was like what is why are you
telling us the most obvious information
ever and he was like well the previous
people who were teaching they all lost
their contract because of a guy or girl
I don't know who it was but like did
something inappropriate so the entire
and it wasn't that company it was a
different and then they got hired so my
contract was only for three months so we
were The Replacements and I guess they
were very eager not to have something
happening any problems yeah but I was
like okay what about the actual like um
teaching part do I don't have any
experience do I need any of that he's
like you'll be fine
how many schools do I have like just
like is it a high school he's like you
have seven and I was like what that's
what I said and I was like what does
that mean he's like you have five
elementary schools and two junior high
schools and I was like but there's only
like five days in a working day and he
was like oh that's right you're gonna go
like you're going to switch schools at
lunch time and uh you have to do these
things whoa this was a very exciting
face and so then after those two days
what were you learning very exciting
because you're terrified well yeah it
was but you know you were in it
I'm in Japan I was like I don't have a
phone I don't have a carrier I didn't
have a phone for my first four months
weird being like totally disconnected
from your home yeah it was and it was it
was tough because you're coming from
something like I had my entire
life's possessions in like two or three
suitcases and uh imagine you know you
weebs with your toys and your pillows
and you're one of the funky weaves yeah
whatever you guys have you I don't know
clothing and then you have to
consolidate all of that down into two
suitcases right yeah oh well then that's
not as cool as it made it sound that's
uh
I didn't have a computer I didn't have
anything the iPhone 3S had just come out
to put this in perspective there are
probably some kids watching this that'll
like the what the what yeah I know it's
so bad and I'm so old but um no it's
cool though but they gave me a car and
they put a washing machine in the back
and they said just drive like eight
hours that way and I was like what do
you mean
I gave you a car yeah yeah I had to have
a car because my my classes were you
know jootsu where I was staying it's not
I mean once you're outside of Target
yeah I know but like they just told us
where did this car come from don't you
know a lot of documents I'm sure you do
need them you know we're just it was
like yeah so I just found a car on the
side of the road
you found this company through Google
right it was actually on Craigslist or
some [__] like that that's the name no
I'm kidding it was actually similar it's
called
um Ohio Sensei and it was a like a
monthly newsletter that they would send
out that had listings of opportunities
okay 95 percent of them were if you're
in Japan here is what oh okay there was
like one that was like We'll hire anyone
I was like that's me so I don't have any
experience driving in Japan I don't even
totally familiar with all the rules not
to mention it's the wrong it's on the
left side right the wrong side did you
have a driver's license I did I was a
pizza delivery man in the United States
so I uh I'm no stranger but did you have
a international license
wait a minute no I'm kidding I I did I
had a okay for Americans those only last
a year and then you can't yes everyone
yeah yeah oh is that right okay yeah
after that do you guys have to take the
test yeah we have to take a test for the
UK but uh in Japan yeah we got to do the
whole thing yeah in Japan if you move
here because you're a resident you're
for the first year you're allowed to use
an international driving license and
then after that you're not allowed to
use it yeah you either have to get a
Japanese driver's license or you have to
convert your current license
okay well
um I had that piece of paper yeah I
drove West or wherever it was and then I
finally after about 11 or 12 hours I hit
the coastline I hit the coastline and
then I had to go south because I
overshot it but like you I got there and
um it was kind of crazy because there
were six other teachers with me
um and we were meeting in like literally
a basement and it it even kind of
reminds me of like a cinematic thing
with like The Swinging lamp and it was
like very low light and like you
people's faces for like two seconds
and people are smoking in there and I
was late and they were like you know so
our final guest and I'm like oh it's
literally like a movie
we were looking at this giant map of
nigata and everybody had a color code
that that signified where we were and I
was like it's like it's like Reservoir
Dogs I'm like Mr Pink or something I was
like I was like I don't see my my things
like anywhere and they're like no you
have to do that because you've already
driven here and I was like okay and then
we like unfurled the map like three
squares and I was over in the mountains
and it was like the most uh kind of
isolated part right right
yeah oh yeah the elementary school had
31 students total so had one first
grader it had like five or six seconds
yeah and I was like hi I'm your English
teacher you know and it was
um to my great surprise though I started
at the junior high school and it's I get
there and they had a grand welcoming for
me and I've mentioned this story before
on my streams or things but I walk out
into this this theater this Auditorium
or gym or whatever and there's like the
brass band playing all eight of them you
know there's like a kid hitting the
symbols and then there's like the
teachers and everyone's clapping and
there was this one kid by like the the
like the wings of the stage yeah he was
like looking for someone and they were
like hit it and he like yanked it down
nothing happened and he like did it
again and it unfurled this ginormous
poster that said welcome Peter
I was like uh given my recent training
I was like better and I was like ah oh
man that's not my name but I'll go with
it oh my God
I guess I'm better now you better see
her let's go and so I was like all right
this is gonna be interesting and you
know some of the things if you're
thinking about being a teacher you need
to realize is you have like a school
lunch which is made by like a
nutritionist and you might get like fish
heads or you know a really healthy thing
a balanced diet yeah a balanced diet and
you get like a carton of milk you don't
get a separate lunch from like the
teachers so it's it's very and you got
to eat with the kids a lot of the time
yeah you go to different classes and
you're like sitting in and you're like
okay I'm too fat for this [__] and
you're like uh Hey kids how you doing
and you're like and you don't know how
to use chopsticks maybe or you know
there's a lot of things you don't know
you're already starting the dependent
culture differences yeah yeah and so for
me I had to do a lot of farming and
agriculture work my because you're in
the mountains because I'm in the
mountains right so I had to teach them
like the names of animals they may
Slaughter or raise I guess or animal
husbandry or like equipment or you know
and then they were like well it's time
for you to go out to the fields and
plant some rice or you know we're gonna
do hard backbreaking labor like what
it's actually shocking the amount of
like schools that still do that to this
day yes I mean in the mountains they
still do that what kind of stuff so for
the UN dokai which is the sports
Festival we planted our own rice so that
by the Harvest time we could enjoy our
our the fruits of our labor
that's cool it's also because like a lot
of these like kids that grow up in these
kinds of environments they end up
working yeah anyway or they go to like
high schools that are like agriculture
based like colleges that agriculture
based so they just like well let's
implant this knowledge into the while
they're young because they're probably
going to end up in that occupation
anyway and the English teacher who's
there by accident
and uh learn our culture do our work
well it was tough because I showed up in
like a suit and I remember uh you know
I'm like hey what's up in there and it's
brutally hot it's not a beach town this
is not a resort it's the most humid City
on planet Earth I swear yeah and uh I
was like they're like today we're gonna
run around this giant you know like two
or three kilometer field that was like
their harvesting field but every morning
the students and teachers all do three
laps to like promote I don't know health
and I was like I'm wearing like you know
a suit and he was like the principal
really really nice guy he was like
and he was like I think I have some old
soccer shorts and he got me some umbros
and umbros are like what I remember from
like eight years old which are like
these sequenced soccer shorts yeah and I
am not the same size of uh an Japanese
man and I put those things on and it was
like the hottest like shorts I barely
got my thigh food you know them and now
I'm like and so I'm running yeah
new teacher so I'm like running in like
dress shoes and umbros in a suit and a
shirt with a tie yeah and I'm like okay
I've made a terrible mistake but these
parts I actually enjoyed these kids had
a real real Charming quality to them
they were very innocent they were very
intelligent and they actually taught me
a lot of things but I needed to quickly
learn that I am not a teacher I am not
I'm not here to promote a lot of the
concepts that you would learn as an
English student in your schools yeah I'm
here to provide the one thing and I
think a lot of English teachers who come
here make this mistake you got to remind
yourself what is the one thing that a
native English speaker has that Japanese
teachers do not and that you can feel
and know the language right yeah so you
can make it interactive you can make it
fun and it doesn't have to be about
grammar and vocabulary and writing stuff
it can be yeah but yeah so that's I
think a lot of people come here with the
expectation of oh well you know I'll be
a teacher no you will not you will be
planting rice and gym shorts or you will
be welcomed with banners that say better
or you know driving to new places but it
has gotten better the last 10 years
certainly since when I showed up yeah I
had high harvesting I really hope so a
lot more mainstream that's for sure yeah
it certainly has and uh but even then
I'd say English teaching was a massive
industry even probably bigger than it is
now due to some changes that they've
made with the way acai was work so
um do you want me to continue this yeah
yeah yeah it's a super fast I've never
heard that you like the entire process
yeah yeah well one second I don't know I
just need a drink this episode is
sponsored by boxu guys soccer season is
just around the corner and every year
boxu is sharing the beauty of the cherry
blossoms by releasing their limited
edition snack collection
but for those of you who don't know let
me tell you about what boxu is boxer
delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tea sourced directly from Century's old
small family businesses right to your
door Connor which one do you want to try
this is the yatsu hasashi senbei is the
little snack that you can get Kyoto by
the way it's very famous oh and we got
the organic again my jersey pairing guys
lovely that goes beautifully with sweets
Joey what's this one I've got here
that's try this one out that's Sakura
Mochi I'm gonna finish this actually
as a soccer Emoji God damn honestly I've
been really enjoying Mochi recently
that's why I picked it I knew it was
Mochi I just wanted Joe to say it so if
you want to have your very own Sakura
celebration and support our Channel
click the link in the description down
below and use our coupon code trash
taste 15 to get 15 off your very first
box of order thank you very much boxy
for sponsoring us today this episode is
sponsored by holds gun you want wood
hell yeah I do well Joey we've got
plenty of wood right here straight from
Austria horse gun is a high quality
watch and jewelry maker that has
numerous and varied designs for men and
women and guess what the majority of
this stuff is made from the highest
quality wood is that a purse made out of
entirely wood that is awesome my name is
Joey now yes look look at that that's
actually honestly Joey what's that on
your wrist right there this right here
this is a high quality hold skirt watch
look at this I love this color this blue
color just someone who wears a lot of
watches this looks sick we're so excited
to be a part of this that we want you
guys to be a part of their Valentine's
promotion guys oh my Lord it runs from
Johnny January 16th to February 5th
which is almost over so get your hands
on it now and just for you guys watching
this video a gift a Valentine's gift
from us to you if you use the coupon
code taste 15 at checkout you get 15 off
your order and a free custom wooden
postcard it's already waiting for get
closer to Nature and smash that link in
the description down below by getting
yourself some horse good back to the
episode uh the three months ended and I
ended up working inside of an itoyokato
for a new Supermarket Giant Supermarket
which has clothing stores it has um shoe
stores toy departments it's like a mall
it's like the Walmart basically yeah uh
but they're all unique stores though
they're all their own little stuff so
this guy who had helped me be a liaison
with the first company I came with he
thought I had some real potential
potential in what teaching like like I I
guess if I you know self-deprecating
aside I think I'm a pretty okay
communicator and I I can motivate very
much so yeah so you got potential kids
so he was like I want to start a new
company with just you as the main
teacher you're the only teacher and
we're going to set up in this this
Supermarket Mall place okay and I was
like okay and uh I'm getting a massive
increase in my salary and I was like
that sounds great he found me an
apartment
um I had to give the car back so it had
to be within walking distance this is
still a new guy and but winter is
approaching I did not know that nigata
leads uh the nation in snowfall every
year oh yeah it's insane oh yeah before
we get to this point what what did you
do about accommodation prior to this did
they give you a place they did okay okay
and they they are they almost every
single Corporation will give you a place
to stay because for more it sounds like
it just sounds like you hit the ground
running you like landed and the next few
days you would
I mean to reiterate again it's no cell
phone there's no I have no PC yeah I um
I don't speak the language certainly was
there ever a point where you're like I
think I made a mistake here almost every
day but uh but see for me no I didn't I
think I'd already kind of the die had
been cast in my opinion and I there are
there are very few honestly speaking I
wake up still to this day and it sounds
so cheesy but I always find something
new in Japan to enjoy or that or that I
like about Japan absolutely yeah and I
knew when I went back to America my
first time during this this career I
thought I miss home as in Japan and I
was like yeah that's that's where I live
now so yeah there was a lot of Trials I
was I was dead broke for about seven
years of my life like right could not
you'd have to choice of like the month
of October like go out and have fun with
my friends once or eat
um I'll go out with my friends and just
make it work so like it was the the
finances especially can be really tight
into Oklahoma and they don't pay a lot
so yeah so like yeah yeah so anyway it
starts snowing a lot I'm working in this
super mall this Supermarket Mall place
and I realized this guy has actually no
business sense at all and uh we have no
curriculum we have no materials but uh I
I show up every day at the uh this this
place and I'm the only guy there and I
didn't know this in these malls all of
the shop owners stand outside when the
when it right when it opens and you all
say like welcome in Japanese yeah I
think the the word for that is
yeah it's kind of cool I was going out
there every morning and I was going
and I was negating that I was like
you're not welcome here because I didn't
hear it right and like it yeah yeah
don't come to my shop I don't care and
then finally this this guy who sold
Italian clothes next to me yeah I never
saw a single purchase there but
he was like he wrote a message and he
was like you are foolish you keep saying
you're not welcome I think he was saying
I made a mistake but yeah yeah I was
like
um
yes I am I and so what ended up
happening a long story short
um this business crumbled almost
immediately okay did you get paid at all
I did but there was real oh I should
mention they did finally get me a work
visa on my second month working so I
worked illegally for about nine weeks
and then they finally got me the thing
so they should have that sounds like it
was they kind of dragged you here didn't
tell you anything it was a mess yeah
that sounds like they did it's almost
like they were like hoping you would
quit after the first couple no I mean
it's just something like they were
needlessly risking because they wouldn't
harm them if you yeah no certainly not
yeah and well I give them some benefit
of the doubt given that yes they were
unorganized certainly but
um there was the big earthquake and
maybe that that slowed down some of the
I don't know that's what I hope it
happens it could be so this guy went out
of business well so we ended up selling
this and sometimes Japanese businesses
get kind of creative with how they sell
programs and things and we had like a
point system where like you could buy 33
million points in each lesson you could
choose to spend 12 000 of them for 50.
and I was like this makes no sense to me
but he wanted people to buy lessons in
bulk so that we would pocket a lot of
initial money and then he lost it all in
Pachinko like every day so oh yes he did
if I needed to find him for something I
didn't have to go far to the local
Pachinko place and he he was like we
were how did he even get this money to
get off the ground I think they gave him
a fairly sizable loan too and uh you
know to do this all they wanted at the
Pachinko yeah he wanted at the Pachinko
come on but I could not imagine going
just to be like where's my boss oh he's
gambling all my wage away yeah well that
and we still didn't have the the right
formula for like what am I teaching
exactly like I don't know what's
happening but I made the best of it that
I could and his brother who spoke about
35 words of English helped write some of
the a b dialogues and those made
absolutely no sense
it's a conversation between two
characters and it'd be like like hello
and he'd be like die and I'd be like
I'd be like I was like I don't think
that's where we should start because
this was at a grocery store and he's
like what to do when you run into a
murderer
I know I know that there is uh malls and
there are different things but I've
never heard of lessons English lessons
given out on a mall no we were pretty
much the pioneers of this one
well to be fair at etoyokato sometimes
you can find a a kaiwa that's kind of
closed off a bit for children but we had
marketed ours for an adult because I was
done teaching kids I've played too much
dodgeball in soccer and it's been you
know I was like I want to try and
planning right I actually wanted to
teach English that's what I thought yeah
and then so his a b dialogues and he
always defended them by saying they're
almost I'd be like so the scene would be
like we're packing for a a trip to
America and I'd say like honey where's
my underwear and she'd be like you ate
it and I'd be like this doesn't make
sense like none of it this is not even
like a real conversation average
American conversation
I was like we need to rewrite these to
be like you know did you what's the
flight number did you confirm the
passport stuff or let's go through like
useful and we had a lot of uh
discussions about this and while he was
just gambling Pachinko right and um
needless to say it kind of became this
finger he wasn't moving his feet to
renew my Visa and uh this now gets into
pretty scary territory where he's like
I'll recontract you for another year but
you know we're not making enough money
you're gonna have to take a huge cut in
salary I was like you've been we hired
like these other people to help like uh
because you know we I needed somebody in
the classroom who spoke Japanese too
yeah help if I was like this is what I
want to tell you yeah and he would miss
their payments for like four months and
they were Japanese really sweet Japanese
women and you're just thinking this is
not working so I I had very little money
left I packed up and I visited a friend
in Tokyo and I had two days to find a
job before I had to go back right and I
I went to various places and I found an
akaiwa which I'd not taught at before
other than my own failed business
venture where you know I was The Prodigy
of English teaching and we found this
one and I thought this is perfect
because the emphasis was English through
drama and I thought that's perfect I can
do that that was the biggest mistake of
my entirety that was the worst job I've
ever had and I and I gotta say if again
just rock up to this place you're like I
want a job well I was begging um but it
was it was something like that I I
remember you know I talked to the guy
and I said listen I I've got to get this
place I don't have a place to live I'm
out of money I'm out of time I can start
any just I have to get out of this and
he was like it's okay mate it's all
right calm down and I I remember he
looked at me right in the face and he
was like you're gonna be a good teacher
and it's going to be all right
welcome home and I said like oh thank
you so much Mr you're so kind and now
he's like time to die you know I was
like oh God it's overworked so anyway
that was the hardest one because you
teach I had this class called Joyland
and Joyland was four hours and it was
two-year-olds and one and a half year
olds and you eat lunch with them you you
sing songs you do things and it's the
hours are from like 11 A.M or 9 A.M to 8
P.M but there's breaks in like the
middle or you know this is the ikaiwa
lifestyle so you have to be ready to be
paid very little and be always on call
and the materials are there for you but
it's it's a really stressful situation
and I I think that was the unhealthiest
I've ever been it was a really tough job
and after about a year of that I I
couldn't hack it I just couldn't do it
and I was like all right I got an
opportunity to teach at a high school
and that was when I started to really
change my Outlook of why I think
teaching is a good job in this country
if you take it seriously and you can
find ways to make it entertaining but
also start adding in a lot more
educational elements yeah then you can
start saying like yeah you know what I
can teach English I'm actually
knowledgeable I've studied this and then
by the end of my career I switched to a
private high school in Tokyo with a
guaranteed like pension with like um a
bonuses and like a imperf I could work
there forever and that's very very rare
in this country so I think to make a
this whole thing make sense if you
really want to be in Japan it's not bad
to be an English teacher it's it's yeah
people are going to make fun of you yeah
you're gonna feel like this is not what
I thought it was okay wait do people
make fun of you yeah of course well okay
I I haven't heard of that though yeah I
haven't heard of that I guess the only
place I've ever heard of it or seen it
is when people try to I suppose you know
people who have moved here and have
managed to move here without going
through the common teaching route I
think there's some kind of like
superiority complex where it's like I
did it not in the way that everyone else
oh yeah I did it in my own way I use my
own skills to get here like I didn't
just apply to this English thing I'm not
like everyone else it's like that and
everything right yeah they want to feel
like they're better so I think yeah for
sure yeah well I mean it has a bad
reputation because the salary is so low
what is that the average so on an egg
highway I mean okay wait let's see this
has been a while since 10 years ago
where I started my first month stuff was
about Juku months about 1900 a month but
I was in the countryside
well you know it changes depending on
the year so like let's just say 100 yen
is a dollar for the sake of arguments
about 1900 yeah it's about 1900 a month
and that was actually pretty good for
that area you know and I was doing all
right and I could live I'm sure the cost
of living was a lot lower so I think my
rent was 400 and I had I had like a
three LDK it was like a tatami room yeah
I had like
um a like a bathroom I live in poverty I
feel like now like
like this table is bigger than my
apartment now so like like it's you know
it was really spacious and it was very
nice but um then when you move to to the
akaiwa it was about 2300 a month which
in Tokyo Yokohama it gets pretty tough
oh yeah yeah especially when you have
like Municipal tax in this country yeah
the rent was 900 a month for me yeah
that was with a discount and um and you
also have to pay things like health
insurance and there's a lot of stuff
that you know then I took a pay cut to
teach at high school and and I worked at
interact which is a very famous
placement company yeah for schools not a
kiowa's and that one paid about and then
of course income tax as well so you
don't take home 23. yeah that was about
2200 a month and it was man there were
times seriously where you I had to eat
just eggs and rice for like six weeks
during because and you need to know this
one thing if you you do work at those
schools they will take out 60 percent in
August because there's no classes so you
get prorated pay see if you whatever
it's 60 of 2200 was you're looking at
like a paycheck that's eight or seven
hundred dollars wait it's just August or
no there's more actually so that's the
biggest one though August August is the
summer holidays yeah they can do that
they do that yes and then you have in
December and January there's like 75 to
80 pay then you have it again in uh
March because the end of school year
this is something that is the hardest
part because some months you'll feel
good and then the holidays come around
and everyone wants to go out and have a
beer or celebrate but the August payment
is two months later so it's right on
that October first pay right you get 700
and you're like you're like this isn't
even gonna pay the rent no it doesn't
and luckily you know if you're
responsible you'll have no problems
if you're responsible
now to kind of give the other side when
I worked at the private high school I
made really really decent money not even
close to what I would consider a teacher
should make of that effort of like how
much you're there but that one was
closer to in a yearly some 35 to 45 000
a year okay which is that's a very
respect and um I had an opportunity to
keep growing that each year I stayed so
that's pretty good then yeah yeah that's
I would say just being honest it's
probably one or two percent of people
can get those opportunities it's called
a direct hire so you cut out the
middleman and you get uh directly like
from the school yeah right right so
those are very hard to get but those are
those are very rewarding and the kids
can be it's a
the last thing you got to remember
though is Japanese work culture man it's
horrible it's the worst yeah it's the
worst yeah
um you will be there sometimes six days
a week if not seven you will do things
outside of the scope of your contract
routinely yeah and you are expected to
go and socialize with co-workers and be
a part of these things whether it's
today we're going to Proctor tests for
eight hours and in Japan that means you
do not move you do not speak you cannot
check your phone and if a student knocks
like their pencil off the table of their
desk they can't even pick it up you have
to go and be like here you are you can't
speak though you just ominously throw it
down in their face so these happen like
six or seven times a year with testing
so those are like weeks of your life
where you're sitting yeah and just
thinking and there's nothing worse than
being left alone with your thoughts on
like a beautiful day yeah so I've never
thought about that I uh yeah because
like I can remember taking tests in like
school and stuff and I can't remember
what my teachers were doing well it was
they would hire examiners they were like
they were like third parties uh people
because obviously the teachers are
teaching still during exams so they
can't they can't oversee the exams oh so
we we have like a whole testing block so
it'd be like all right it's finals or
university entrance examination kind of
pre-test yeah so all the teachers have
no classes but we take a buddy system
right and you'd sit there for night
stand there for 90 minutes and just
make sure no one's cheating and it's
like man this is brutal and uh those
things are like today we're having a
satsume Kai which is like an
informational day because we got to
recruit students so everyone down to the
arena so we can set up 475 chairs
manually you know like setting these
things and pulling them out of the thing
and then you do all this stuff like
waiting and in Japan you're like you say
that like 4 000 times I come this way
and then after you don't know where the
[__] the entrance is it's not just the
entrance you guide them along like 18
people are pointing you to like oh my
God a straight line and you're like okay
and they always put the you know they
put me out front because I got a winning
smile and uh Hey welcome and the parents
are just like walking by and you're like
okay
um but those outside of the teaching
stuff is a major part of your work and
you'll sit in meetings legitimately for
six or seven hours and you have no idea
what's being talked about yeah and I'll
lean over to like an English teacher I'm
like what are we talking about she's
like they're discussing sock colors and
I'm like what we've been here for three
hours I was like purple blue
and they're just like no this is a very
important discussion so we it it's those
things Amplified times a hundred what
are they like trying to figure out the
[__] hexadecimal so the the shift
would be hard anyway having to do it and
on top of that you have hours upon hours
of time where you just feel like your
time is being wasted and unbelievably so
it yeah because like I I interned under
the Japanese tech company during college
for like three months uh in Tokyo like
in Shibuya right
um and those three months were more than
enough time for me to be like I do not
want to be part of this cycle because it
was exactly the same like I had when I
was employed like I had like a set list
of things that was my job like
day-to-day basis right it's like you
know I did like website design and like
SEO design and stuff like that but
ninety percent of the day was [__] that
I had a no expertise in or B I had no
knowledge in so I was like forced to
like sit with like these clients for
this company and they're talking about
some kind of [__] higher end business
[__] and I'm just sitting there being
like why am I dude do you want me to
like take notes and they're like no no
just be here why am I here I could I
could have finished my job today by now
if I didn't have this meaning so it's
like no no you have to be either it's
company policy I'm like is it because
I'm not [__] doing anything
and that is the reality it's horrible
it's also he speaks Japanese so yeah I'm
just sitting there and it's like I have
I hate when people say I have ADHD right
but I like literally have it like yeah
yeah I was like the first kid who had it
and the treatments like when we were
kids I remember
um my mom took me to like this ADHD
they were like invented
they put you in all these different
pills which my mom I think was like I'll
just take those you don't need them and
I was like those are uppers aren't they
and I'm like okay but they they gave me
uh they gave me these headphones that
were like giant like 1970s cans yeah and
I had to listen to whales communicating
for like three hours a night to try to
calm your mind and I was like this is I
was like I thought that was just like a
meme no I am the meme so yeah I am
that's me holy [__] we did that we
didn't help
um I don't think I'm stable
I think I I don't know what happened to
me but like I don't think it helped I
was like eight or nine okay and so I was
a kid and so like I had some real real
issues uh but my mom was very patient
but like you know the ADHD part of me
when you're sitting in a room for seven
hours and you can't read a book you
can't you can't oh my God you just have
to sit there so it did that actually
helped me more than the whales did
because you really learned to be totally
patient with like the opportunity but
I do feel bad I want to say one thing
really quick about teaching because I've
totally [__] on it for like 30 minutes
right teaching can be really fun it's in
the classroom is I think with high
school especially it can be really
satisfying and very rewarding and you
get to see some kids make like genuine
progress and I like preparing my own
lessons I like doing that stuff yeah um
though I did it for probably nine years
too long but I still think if that's the
job that gets you into a country you
want to be in whether it's Japan or
somewhere else I would I would take it
still I have no regrets over those
experiences that I have a lot I'm
leaving out all the funny stories but
like I mean you have a treasure
those those experiences are definitely
they've helped me in so many different
ways but yeah my advice would be find
another outside the school's income
something to supplement it something
like um private lessons or if you have
some other skills you join a hobby that
pays somehow that will help you enjoy
your life in Japan more than the the
working 75 hours a week yeah but yeah
those are all very different experiences
but they're all very it was a it's
pretty [__] on by everybody most people
if you ask them like what do you do in
Japan they'll be like
um
I teach English but I also teach yoga
once every three months that's awesome
but you know we kind of meme it up a bit
to each other it's kind of like uh you
know we're like ah another day teaching
English you know it's it's tough yeah
that's what I see I think it's pretty
it's pretty mocked so how did you go
like
um how did you go and dump your process
of like planning lessons and stuff like
that did you just like make it up on the
floor like you probably have to like
follow a curriculum basic plan right we
have a curriculum or something to follow
you so it varies depending on the school
but I'll give you like two or three
examples sometimes the curriculum is 100
either faxed to you from the company
like today's colors you know
um and it'll be like this is the layout
this is the intro this is the middle or
the or you'll have a giant book that has
a this is the sequence of lessons we're
teaching this year today's lesson is
this yeah um and then the other ones
that's step one that's usually like an
AK Iowa or Elementary School
it's pretty simplified and
straightforward yeah second one is like
I would say the Middle School area where
you have or early High School like eat
first-year students you work very
closely with an English teacher who is
their Japanese primary the Japanese
teacher who teaches English that makes
sense yeah okay sorry then they will say
you know I'm really I've taught them
this grammar point but I'm having
trouble making an activity so that we
could reuse it or like make it fun so
then you're like okay well let me uh let
me see what I got let me put on the
clown shoes real quick okay I've got
that ready to go and um it's like
Superman but you just have the buttons
that are just in your legs and I start
putting on the makeup uh those are yeah
the common ones are like a bingo or a
Jeopardy or some sort of interactive
dialogue or you know and then when you
get into High School one of my favorite
things was I actually well if I must
admit I made my own textbook thank you
and it never got published but you know
I got to use it in the class that I
taught but for me it was the perfect
opportunity because they said we've
created a class just for you we want you
to teach these students but we we're
leaving it open-ended to you but I need
you to write up a a detailed like yearly
outline like what is your your pedagogy
what are you gonna try to bring to them
what are the midterms what are the
finals how's it being school all that
stuff right and I I really used my
previous six years of teaching and it
was really kind of nice to be able to
put all of those ideas into to one
single package and so yeah as you get
more experience and I think if you take
it seriously you have a lot more control
over how you want those lessons to go
but sometimes you can tell immediately
you get in there and you're like oh I
got the best game ever we're gonna play
this cool rock scissors paper game and
like 10 minutes later you're like this
shit's horrible and no one's having fun
you look at the clock and you're like
that wasn't even 10 minutes I was three
I got 47 more minutes and then you're
like all right clean up clean up
everybody everywhere
that this [__] always works so you learn
a lot about which I think has helped me
in acting definitely ha that degree was
useful yeah you know being agile or
being able to think on your feet and
improvising improvising is a massive one
and it's kind of cool you get this you
talk to teachers who've done it for a
while you get this internal clock where
you you don't even need to see the thing
anymore like on the wall you already
know that that's that game has already
been long enough yeah so let's let's
wrap it up and go to this other thing
and if I need to add or detract some
time no it's awesome it's a really fun
feeling being you know the your own
little star of a classroom is it's fun
oh yeah but that's that's how you make a
lesson yeah I gotta ask because like you
know we would we've seen we see like
high school movies and everything like
that and in America there's normally
like some delinquents and stuff like
that I gotta know because like my image
of Japanese school kids is that they're
very well behaved and stuff like that
um is that is that true or not so I
would say 97 of students are very well
behaved if not too behaved where you're
like it's
yeah and so but then you I did teach at
a school once that was a delinquent
level school where they had been
delinquent level school yeah so if you
don't as a school that all the
delinquents conglomerate yeah and so one
kid could have you know had a you know
violent past the other kid could just be
really shy and then these two girls
could just be like I just need to I
dropped out but like you got to teach
some and those are the ones where it's
really awkward you're like today's
lessons is and then somebody
back-to-back titties and you're like
nope that's not today's lesson he's like
ball sack and you're like no it's not on
there either do you want to try again
he's just like titty ball sack and I'm
like are you a student you look 31.
he'll be like oh
and then he'll like leave or something
and you're like okay those you do get
kids like I remember one I we had a
group photo right and I felt so bad for
this co-teacher she's quite young and
she was like 24 25 and we taught this
course and all of them were a sports
course so they were like really into all
of the things that a you know a
hot-blooded young man will be into and
and you know that's not great to be in
that scenario with this poor young
teacher and we took a group photo and
right at the last second three of the
baseball boys dropped their pants and
they're just like in their Whitey
tighties just posing and this is like
for the school and I'm like we can't
have that let's try taking that again
yeah and then six kids took their pants
off oh no I was like all right that's
I'm getting fired so like how was your
English lesson I was like well we
stripped and then kids were swinging
their you know there those kids are very
rare but I think once they learn a bad
word oh man or they'll be they'll say
like Peter Sensei and I'll be like yeah
he's like and I'm like what's that word
and it's boobs yeah and I'll be like
I've never heard that he's like I was
like no I've eaten the top he's like and
you're like uh I've never heard that and
then they'll just keep digging it deeper
and to get a reaction
so you could say to yourself uh I sound
like YouTube comments yeah yeah well
those kids are they're they're they're
memorable but it's pretty rare because
I'd say most kids are extremely well
behaved right yeah yeah but you do get
some characters who who want to learn
about the different words of they've
seen on an American TV show or right or
they watch this podcast or you know
they've learned some new words yeah yeah
that part can be tough but in high
school at the private one you got to be
pretty straight laced and yeah yeah for
sure one complaint I often hear
um teachers or Japanese teachers um are
foreigners teaching uh English in Japan
is that um it often feels like you're
very replaceable like you're you're
almost always made you feel that like oh
we're waiting for you to leave so we can
get the next person in like there's
almost a sense of you you're not valued
as like a member of the team in a sense
I don't know if I'm capturing that
question oh you're you're definitely the
are we are we recording this or yeah
yeah yeah I'll just I thought you were
just we didn't stop recording by the way
so
um
you're definitely not a core part of the
the team in fact a lot of the times
they'll sit The Foreigner group into
their own little square if not in a
different room completely Jesus Christ
and then that's actually better actually
than being a part of the group sometimes
because then you have shared tasks but
the thing you mentioned is I think the
turnover rate is so high for teachers in
Japan that the the the the real teachers
don't want to get a chance to get to
know you attached or figure out your
methods it's just hey man you just gotta
do it and another thing is it's actually
a rule in Japan that every six or seven
years the all of the teachers must
rotate out of the school so you can't oh
yeah this is a real thing so you'll be
is that reason why I think it's to
encourage not resting on your laurels or
or wait every every teacher every
teacher so you'll go and teach with a
guy like you know Mr uh Ishikawa or
something and he'll be like two years uh
in two years he's gone like that's it
but another teacher was there for like
five more so you you kind of get used to
that or a teacher will come back and
then he'll be like ah not skushy it's
very nostalgic I used to work here 14
years ago and you're like wow okay so
they get sent to different schools and
sometimes that's
literally a horrific change because you
can go from like a really great school
that has model students to a a
delinquent school or or to a tech school
or those are not bad schools but I mean
like you could be used to something yeah
that can be very stressful yeah and uh
the same is for the the foreign teachers
we um unless it's a private school you
can be hired there forever which is my
last job but the other ones you get used
to the shuffle and it's a it's a
terrible dread when you go to the the
meetings and you're like what's my
assignment this year or on the a Kiowa
you might have when I was an AK Iowa
teacher for the drama one I had about
five different locations like all around
Japan I'd be like yo Yogi which is in
Tokyo and I'd be like in kemioka which
is the opposite end of the Oklahoma or
you have like a different day you'd go
to a different Studio Jesus at the
beginning of the year you'd get your new
assignment and it'd be like six new
places that may or may not be anywhere
close to your home
all right this year please give me the S
yeah every time I think there's
something Japan can'tify they prove me
wrong baby I got you got your occupation
yeah I got that I never got an S by the
way
that's a uh that's a I've heard of a few
cases where someone had been uh given
their location where they were going to
teach in Japan and it was so remote or
[__] that they just didn't enjoy it and
they just left like nigata well this is
one of the better ones well I mean yeah
because you could be really remote like
boats or yeah I I had a friend who
taught in the middle of the mountains in
Mia oh man and that's like really
[__] middle yeah and people would
just leave they wouldn't say anything
they would just I'm going back to Turkey
I'm getting the flight back I'm not
doing this yeah it's especially really
you know Jets notoriously a jet is a
government-sponsored program I think
it's called like the Japanese exchange
teaching program or something like that
but they have great money and great
benefits and a lot of holiday time and
that's if you do want to come and teach
I highly recommend that's the first
option right yeah right they guarantee
you some some money but the thing is
it's the great gotcha of our day you
have very little agency in where you are
placed yeah so you you passed the
interview and they ask you was there any
particular location you'd like to to
teach at because everyone says
that actually I've heard eliminates a
lot of the people like oh really because
for a long time Jets were not in Tokyo
until just about four or five years ago
they finally opened it back up but if
you say like Osaka Tokyo Yokohama
they'll be like they don't want you
because they can probably suss out that
you're here for an anime pop-up
convention or like another activity or
something that's you're focused
experience the real Japan that's that's
a quick way but yeah you'll get people
who you know I met Jets when I was in
you got there and they would just be
like I don't know what I'm doing here
I've been here three years and it's like
it's so much snow but I like
snowboarding now and you're like okay
but you're right you could get sent to
ahime which is a beautiful place but
it's nowhere near it's a different route
it's not very eventful yeah that's very
true people will just that's how I got
my job or no mine was because of the
yeah the other one yeah the other one
the other one Prince Andrew's stuff
I probably can't say that but that's why
we got kicked out or they got kicked out
but like it was not uncommon
we were okay but like the previous
people yeah
the those
there were a lot of times where someone
would like just be like they just
ghosted even at my private schools right
when covet hit uh this guy this Texan
was like I'm out and he left in the dead
of night with his wife damn I don't know
like one of the last flights out of
Tokyo and we have like a a full he's a
teacher and so they were like oh Peter
doesn't say you have a new uh you have
six more lessons this year and I'm like
well do I get six more times paid or is
that how does that work are we giving up
his his nope we're not okay well he's
just literally just left and he just
left and uh I think he was a little bit
concerned with uh the upcoming year of
like what his responsibilities were he
was probably happy in the job itself and
I think he was like you know what I'm
not gonna be here for this covet thing I
don't know the deal I don't know and
then he just gone and he he messaged me
he called me and he was like what's up
man it was like maybe 9 30 at night for
me yeah and I was like dude where are
you at are you at like a studio what's
that he's like that's the sun I'm at
home in Texas and I was like what I was
like the the cornea virus is like Corona
I had no idea what it was I had no idea
yet it was still like we didn't know
what was going on yeah and I was like
that should still out and he was like
yeah I left man and uh if you want that
TV you gave me I left the door unlocked
and I was like what you live like you
just it's you just you left the
furniture and everything out so yeah
that does happen so Jesus Christ yeah
because it's a big problem right I
suppose you can there's nothing
essentially stopping you from just
upping and leaving and oh yeah Japanese
people you hear about Japanese people
doing it all the time where they just
want to escape they're like sick of
their work or whatever and they just
it's called in Japanese but it's like
it's literally just escaping at night
and just [__] leaving everything
behind just out yes and just going
somewhere whether it's in Japan or a
different country take the PS5 though
yeah it doesn't fit in the backpack
I don't know where this resolve comes so
many people I suppose the job is that
Soul crushing that sometimes you just
wake up one day [__] it I'm done yeah
I'm just like I need a change yeah it's
crazy sometimes you just need to like
and that's why and that's one of the
reasons why like in this uh day and age
like the the process of like uh renting
an apartment or a house or whatever it
is is so strict because yeah they've had
so many instances of tenants just
[__] up and leaving and then that
causes all sorts of problems to not just
like the building but also like the
insurance company all that kind of stuff
so that's why that's one of the few
reasons why like it's so hard to get an
apartment here because they're like we
gotta give you this apartment but you
better not [__] run away yeah and
it's it's kind of sad that that's like
the measure that they have to take yeah
it's uh it's a stark reality when you
enter the world of Education yeah or
just or just Japanese words yeah I think
out of anyone I've ever met you've had
the most interesting side quests in
Japan the stories yeah I've had wise
mentioned you need to supplement your
income so if you were to I mean you can
I'm just really tell some of the stories
they don't if this isn't a movie some of
the stuff that you got up to in Japan
everyone would be like this is the
stupidest movie ever made may it would
be it would be the stupidest movie ever
made why did anyone do this I mean and
uh I've had so many random jobs I my
first one that I can remember doing
besides I worked for NHK for a while
that was kind of cool how did that all
come about so I found an advertisement
or someone told me that they you know
it's an open call and it's a show where
they have like eight to ten foreigners
and they're all from different countries
and they say like today's theme is
something Japanese it could be like
bentos and then they sent three of the
foreigners out on location somewhere and
they experience a different kind of
binto maybe this is the most expensive
one maybe this is the most beautiful one
right
um and then we talk about like ubuntos
and America dude would never work
because there's no burgers
yeah but like it was tough because you
had to represent the entire nation right
of America that's an overwhelming power
and so I get to say all the opinions and
then be like well if they're right or
wrong it doesn't matter but you have to
be very careful you just say things like
as far as I know bone in is best and
then you'd have like I'm just saying as
an example as an example tell me how you
really feel bone in is best
so but yes
um that's all of America's opinion don't
worry yeah on behalf of me
so it was that kind of job was cool
because they gave you you know a couple
hundred bucks a month and you get to be
on TV and since I was a theater
background it did Keep Me connected with
like oh this is exciting this is yeah
this is yeah performing entertainment
yeah I I didn't hang my hat on it
thinking like I've made it you know but
like it was a cool thing and then I I
got to be an extra in a movie in Japan
which was awesome it was called
Vancouver
and uh it was a baseball movie and I um
the sunrise of Vancouver the sunrise
Vancouver it was like a uh it was set in
like 1920 and I I was like and I went to
the costume things we went out some
field in the middle of God knows where a
side Tama or something and they were
like
uh Peter Davis I was like Macy they're
like okay
I was like all right that'll work and
then he was like uh you're like the last
guy and they were like well we have is
like a medium and you're more of an l
and I was like oh so like the jacket
like didn't fit and I it like scrunched
on I look like homeless and I so I was
like no I'll give my character like a
you know like some backstory yeah I'll
give him like a name and I and his name
was Chester Flint it was a cool name but
um and then I I was you know I was
getting into it and I decided all of my
scenes took place at like a bar so I I
just always made sure that anytime they
said action I was like the lowest one on
the table kind of like barely just like
drinking as much as and if ever there
was food placed in front of me Chester
always needed like a little bit of
because he didn't know his next meal was
coming so I had like the best night ever
for like two days I got to eat and drink
for free although it wasn't beer it was
like just flavored water but I I went
all in on that character and I thought
you know I think I've got a real career
here uh no did not but like that was
still cool because I got money for it
yeah hell yeah and right as I was coming
back from that I had I had booked with
an agency somehow
and they said we have this audition for
you to be a a model for a furniture
company called okamura okay that's a
legit furniture company I was like I was
like yeah sounds cool man and I go there
and again just like the baseball film
they had the wrong name they were like
are you the cameraman and I was like oh
no I don't have any equipment and
they're like [__] it you're in and uh it
was me and about 35 French models who
were like six two and jacked like I'm
talking perfect bodies yeah and I was
like all right this is so bad I'm this
is so awkward and we had a group
audition yeah and I was like the last
guy
and there was four of us in our group it
was three French guys and me and we had
to go up it's like the top four the
okamura you know sales the presidents
were waiting yeah and I remember the
French guy didn't hold the door open for
me it kind of like slammed into my foot
and then I put and then I knocked over
this plant and this dirt went everywhere
and I was like I'm so sorry and they're
like it's okay and I was like I'm
starting to feel nervous I'm starting to
feel like I don't think I look right for
this job I feel like it's all bad and we
sit on these stools and they said you
know just introduce yourself and the the
French guys were like in perfect
Japanese they were just like saying like
I've been modeling for six years I've
worked with you know uh Gucci and and
Prada and all these things and then they
get to me and I'm like hi I was uh I
like hamburgers and baseball and uh I
was in a movie recently called it's not
out yet but then they were like okay
this guy and the you know the sales
staff is kind of watching me and taking
a note and they're like see why is he
here and um I I was like okay just you
got this man just you know keep being
funny keep being you yeah and they were
like now we just want to see you guys
talk to each other and you can have like
a moment where we're just seeing you
guys move naturally through the thing
and I was like okay so I turned to talk
to the guy and and he immediately starts
talking to like his French buddies like
just the three of them and I was like
I took French a little bit and I was
like I was like and then they kind of
just totally ignored me yeah and I
turned back and I was looking at the
sales staff and I was like I'm sorry man
I don't think I'm actually supposed to
be here and he was like you said you
like baseball and I was like yes I do he
was like what team do you like and I was
like yakult swallows or kind of a fun
team because they've got the uh The
Umbrellas he was like that's my favorite
team and so we started talking and I
ended up getting the job to be a model
for okamoto hell yeah so I was so
awesome [__] you guys I was you know
they they must have gone back to Gucci
and proud I went there so I can't
believe we missed okamura yeah anyway
back to Louis Vuitton yeah yeah and um I
the thing was we had to take a
shinkansen from Osaka it was my first
time taking a shinkansen I was so
nervous I could not even sleep the night
before right I was just like of what
model
[Music]
no no but like I was so nervous about
this opportunity because it paid a fair
amount of money and I was like oh my God
this is why am I modeling I was like
what possible reason would they and I go
there and it's it's like this really
beautiful woman and like this really
handsome guy and then I'm there as well
and they're like your clothes were over
here and it was like this really tight
yellow Polo that was kind of see-through
and I you could see like you know like
my belly button and I was like feeling
like oh [__] this is so awkward and I
walk out there with like my chinos and
shirt and they're like oh we might need
to do some changing of the shirts and I
was like yeah yeah it's fine though and
they were like is that how you like your
hair and I was like uh I don't know you
know like so I I realized in almost
every scene that I was in I was either
at the back and they always instructed
me that like I couldn't get the fax
machine to work or I'm walking past like
a window with like dropping folders and
so all of my character was like oh
camera hires idiots too and I and I was
like well do I have like a cool part
where I'm like and the you know the
office chair and I'm like I have like a
cigar and I'm I'm doing like a business
deal and they're like no no that's these
guys you're gonna be like serving coffee
or you spilled it on yourself and I was
like damn this is fun
I I had to take that and I I parlayed
that into a a job where I was a Model A
second modeling where this one was for a
punching bag so you can buy that at Don
Quixote it was um I still have a like I
like the blue waffles yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got I was on that one and I'm
like well you're on the box yeah yeah
I'll I'll bring it here you guys could
put that on the floor oh yeah at the
very bottom but so like that one was
cool because they brought this girl from
like the Ukraine and she was like
absolutely the most beautiful person
I've ever seen and she was like I have
200 jobs in three days let's make it
quick and I was like I was like wow this
is so sick I'm like a real deal and they
were like all right so uh you're gonna
be like you know holding her back she's
like aggressively punching this bag and
she felt really uncomfortable like not
because of me I hope but uh yeah she was
like don't touch me you know what I'm
like I don't know but they said she's
really not getting the look can you go
in there and just gesticulate like your
her job so she can see what it looked
and I was like yeah that's fine so I got
to do like two jobs for once and then
when we finally got it I gotta say the
final product she looks great I look
really stupid but uh they combed my hair
like super to the side and I need to see
this picture yeah it's like four
different images on the box and uh my
students would find it at Don Quixote
and they'd be like
and I was like no no I don't know that
man
it was tough and then uh in addition to
that I got into some voice acting work
where I worked for a cult here in Japan
where I did the voices
[Music]
how did this opportunity come around
like well this was actually one of the
first uh opportunities I had was because
when in nigata I met a member of that
church and they they said you have such
a lovely voice and I was like yeah
I was like yeah that's pretty cool and
they were like you know you should do
work for our our El cantare or whatever
and I was like what I was like no I
haven't had that on the menu yet I was
like what's that
they were like no no that's uh that's
the great but I was like oh okay I miss
her but like you know and so I
came to Tokyo and it was like when I was
so young man and um
well I was 31.
I knew I was I was young comparatively
yeah so I had to clarify that but like
we we go in there and um I I go into
this this this gilded building it's this
18-story massive place they have them
all around Japan and I I go in there and
they were like yeah welcome and I swear
to God I'm not making this up the girl
who was like the receptionist yeah must
have been 21 22 23 really young really
attractive and she had the size on dog
as a stuffed a big stuffed animal yeah a
hugged to her chest and she was like
welcome and she'd say like can you say
welcome and then she would like talk as
the dog to me and I was like all right
let's go and so I was like uh which one
do I reply to do I talk to the dog dude
I was like hi hi you know and so they
were like all right well we gotta go up
to the top floor and we have your script
ready and stuff and I said okay we go to
the top and um the script had way too
many English mistakes like it was it was
incomprehensible yeah like it didn't
even make any sense so they said all
right well wheel out the YouTube videos
of his speeches and then you can just
read that along but with you know like
him yeah and I said okay we'll set it up
for me what's the deal and they were
like all right do you know like who
Jesus is I was like yes
I'm aware I've heard the name before
they were like all right imagine that
you can hear Jesus talking to you I was
like okay I went to Catholic school for
a year I know what that's like they're
like man Santa and I was like
that's a very different voice and then
they're like and you have like the
prophet Muhammad or you have
um El cantare which I guess is another
being or Buddha or any she listed like
nine or ten different royalties yeah and
and she said when you hear their voices
which is what our leader hears you have
to imbue that in English so you have to
do like nine different voices I had to
feel nine different voices at just every
religion out in the world yeah and I'm
not trying to be disrespectful of course
any religion obviously but like this is
what I was told yeah and I was like okay
this is really hard because I am
unfamiliar with some of the ones we're
mentioning and I was like do I just just
they're like you're fine just you know
so they wheel out the TV and I'm looking
at it and I'm like okay let's go and it
was I sat there and I said well you know
what just give it kind of a general
stage voice and I I was like okay start
I was like the heavens have spoken and
we can delete and recover all universes
and they're like it's not a question I
was like no I know I was just reading
that and
I was like all right can I try that
again and they were like yeah but we
really couldn't hear you know the voices
I was like what was your voice I was
like was there any one in particular was
it like Santa that I was missing and so
I was like all right so we do take two
and uh they were like just give it more
and I was like all right all right so I
was like you know the heavens have
spoken and the deletion of universes is
nigh and they're like stop it's still
not feeling it and I was like all right
well I learned one thing in theater
school it's way easier to tell someone
to do uh less than it is to encourage
people to do more yeah also good for
teaching advice you know it's it start
them off as big as you can and say
that's amazing let's keep most said but
scale it back so I went full Dynasty
Warriors like three with it I was like I
was like if they want to hear the voices
I'll go with whatever the most
ridiculous and I was like
you know I was like I'll move this a
little bit further I was like the
heavens have spoken and then the girl
was like
I'm in creation and then they were like
that's great we did that [__] for two
hours
I had the best time of my life I was
like that's great and so uh but then and
I'm not making this up I wish I was they
right around the two hour mark these
like eight or nine dudes came in fully
like robed up with gilded robes on the
top and I swear on all of the voices
that they on one of the pillows they had
a gilded dagger this golden dagger and
they were carrying it to the front for
like a sermon of some sort and she's
like our session's done and I was like
okay am I walking out of here alive or
what's going on and then they tried to
like recruit me into the if they you
know they thought I had the voice and so
they said we could if you want to come
back and do it again you need to be a
member of the the the group and I was
like yeah
I'd love to but I'm hearing some
disagreements so I'm gonna I'll get back
to you on that and they were like here's
a matsuya meal ticket enjoy your day in
addition to the money I was paid okay
I was like oh nice you know
I was like nice it's a beef bowl so even
though they had coupons yeah they do
surprisingly well they did when I did
that or maybe it's only for select for
religious cultures so we I had that
opportunity and I mean that's such a
long story I kind of detract I got
derailed on my own but yeah yeah so and
then you kind of have those
opportunities come up every once in a
while and I've always been of the mind
to like take them fully and and if if
you get some extra money out of it it's
it's cool and then of course you know
that me being in all these weird places
and having all these weird experiences
kind of helped me be ready to do things
I think where I transitioned out of
teaching so that's that was a it was a
long nine years and there was other
weird modeling jobs and there was other
weird kind of like oh so you got into
this whole Rabbit Hole of just modeling
then from this one or or just like odd
jobs
yeah the some of the bad ones that you
can still find on YouTube it's like I I
uh I had to do I I was like a I was like
an English textbook that they use all
over southeast Asia and Japan and people
will see me on like what I undo now and
streaming and they'll say like I just
saw you in my class today and I'm like
hello cajo which notebook is yours the
blue one or the light blue one and
she'll be like the blue one I'm like
they're both blue
whose notebooks are these
they don't have names
sorry that's mine
which one is yours kahoe the blue one is
both are blue
and then it's like I was like well I
wish I could have that one back here I'm
like welcome to Sunshine Pizza what's
today's offer gonna be but you know
um those are there but I think if you
ask my friends in addition to Japan uh
among my friends group I I have I had so
many random jobs in America that from
like from the ages of 18 to you know
moving it was just an endless cycle of
like its own Netflix series so yeah it
was weird is it just because you say yes
to like everything yeah because I feel
like you do yeah yeah I think I'm here
today
and I'll say yes there was three French
guys upstairs like are those the normal
guests they can't make it and I'm like
I'll fill in but uh I think for me I got
this really cool advice as a young actor
and I think the hardest thing to acquire
is unique experiences and I think a lot
of people fall into routines and I I do
too but I am always keeping an ear open
or you know some kind of opportunity no
matter what if I can get a unique
experience out of that then I think it's
worth doing absolutely yeah absolutely
yeah that's just good life advice I will
make a bad decision I know it's a bad
decision oh my God the story will be
good though it will be a good day it
will be a fun story that's the best and
get something out of it you know yeah
and I I mean I think that a lot of
people have told me I've had a very
colorful life and a lot of interesting
experiences but I think yeah but those
opportunities do come to a lot of people
I think it's just it's easier to just be
like ah nah I don't want to do that yeah
for sure you know because even if it
seems like kind of trivial and like not
important at the time it most of the
times you think about that you know five
ten years later and you're like [__] I
should have done that I should have done
that El cantare voice all the problem is
you don't know what crazy stuff you're
missing exactly yeah yeah you might not
have been El cantare oh yeah for two
hours I heard it all the voices of every
every religion especially
stuff that's happened in Japan that
we'll never get to hear about because
nobody's documenting or talking yeah
yeah exactly
um
it's a weird it's a really wild ride and
uh I wouldn't trade it for a thing
honestly I think
um even though those years were very
hard but yeah finally at the the ancient
age of 39 I've been able to see it
through those those tough Parts but I'm
glad it was in Japan I really do love it
here yeah yeah and then obviously now
you're you're a Twitch streaming
full-time right that's your much to my
family's great shame uh no my mom loves
it yeah if you thought teaching was bad
no but I think you know Twitches or
streaming or YouTube or what any of you
guys have done podcasting it just it
just seems like every time I taught you
it was like streaming was like maybe
yeah yeah
all the experiences you have and like
your background and everything yeah it's
just you know you can Shine the way you
want to really well I appreciate it
means that you have a very interest I I
like when you talk to me about it
because I find that because you weren't
raised online no well actually before
you guys you know I was raised like on
the base of the internet right like the
beginning of AOL instant messenger and
e-bombs world and you're the man now dog
and things that don't exist anymore
there were memes way before we had words
for memes yeah um but then I took a nine
year break when it really blew up
because from 2000 and uh when the 11 was
the Toca earthquake yeah I didn't even
have a PC for eight years so I missed of
course you see it on the phone and stuff
but when when YouTube really became a
career in the late 2000s and it kind of
opened these opportunities on Twitch
like 2010 2011. I I was on the sidelines
on that and I you guys have such
knowledge of it but the things that we
had back then are are still we dial up
and Net Zero and if you had DSL in your
your apartment blocks or your houses
everyone will just come over to your
house to use the internet oh yeah it was
a it was the wild west back then I think
it was the cooler yeah it was actually a
lot more fun I think how did you find
out about twitch then all right so it's
actually really interesting because no
it's not I don't know why but
I had been into watching like Justin TV
and stuff for Evo and fighting game
tournaments yeah and then twitch came
about when I had started teaching at a
high school and I started watching a
ridiculous amount of hearthstone during
the initial blow up of like twitch and I
started getting into all of that stuff
and then I started streaming myself a
little bit I bought a PlayStation Eye
camera and I tried and I I used the
indoor PlayStation live streaming I
tried I was like yeah I'm not feeling
this at all like it it was I wasn't
ready for that opportunity yet yeah I've
never seen somebody stream uh using the
built-in like streaming tools however
I've seen one I've tried it once I've
seen one person do it who had a
substantial viewership really you know
who it was no it was like uh he told me
uh the the Hitomi
he's pulling stuff yeah she was playing
uh if you don't know her yeah you might
know her you will know her you probably
don't know you know her yeah
um but yeah she I remember she still
streams on Twitch now yeah she just
plays fortnite wow it's a built-in
PlayStation seriously holy [__] no no
commentary nothing it's just her playing
fortnite and I guess people are just
like I could imagine every second it was
it was tough I was I remember OverWatch
just come out right and I I was playing
that on the built-in stream 16 doesn't
that feel crazy yeah
[Music]
I was streaming that and I was playing
as Hanzo and I was you know I was kind
of like [__] Hans I mean well yeah at
least he's not a Genji mate yeah day one
of playing you know I was just feeling
it out you know I hadn't I'm a Zenyatta
man really the cool dude with the rose I
don't play OverWatch it's a pretty game
anyway but I was anyway I I was doing
this thing and I I hit some dude with
the head shot and you know everyone's
first stream uh you know I was like
hey good shot
and this guy somehow took the time to
like use the built-in PlayStation thing
and he was like you are [__] and I was
like yeah I am I was like what's up man
are you hello and then he never replied
and I was like oh maybe that was the one
and done you know that was it all right
but like it didn't feel right it didn't
feel fun it didn't have the things I
didn't have the tools available to make
it what I wanted what I'd seen yeah so I
was like ah all right I'm done with this
and it wasn't until you know Kobe that I
got back into it but yeah it is a very
interesting platform for people like me
because it caters to what I grew up with
I think the most which I'm still what I
would consider a dying breed on Twitch
which is really centered on on games and
now I'm not saying that's not popular of
course but I think that what twitch and
YouTube streaming has done so well is
there's these people innovating on it
and doing bigger and more interesting
and like actual events right yeah but
I've always just wanted to recreate a
kind of game nights with my buddies when
we used to play Halo 16 player when I
was in high school and twitch does it
was the best it was it was the best of
times having Lan parties and land
parties it was something that unless you
were there you you I'm very jealous I
never got I never got to experience like
Lan parties I used to have Civ two land
parties back in like God middle school
is so [__] fun none of my friends
games like all the players knew how to
set that up yeah man it was like because
those days you I didn't even have an
Xbox right but I had a big enough
basement so that everybody could come
over and bring their Xboxes people we'd
bring three TVs so people would have to
move there and this is not flat screens
these are not so these big asses
monsters yeah and we'd throw those in
the back and you'd bring I had my own
controller because you know there was
there was even wireless controllers yet
you just had like a wrapped up thing
yeah and we would we would all bring
over uh everybody had to bring over two
cases of soda that was the rule two
cases
every Midwest kid has a refrigerator in
the garage as well yeah so we would have
250 260 cans in there and more and then
we'd have the four TVs two in one room
and then two in my bedroom and they
would all be connected with four feet
eight on eight or whatever you were
playing yo we would start at like seven
seven thirty and stop 12 hours later my
mom would go to work on Saturdays and I
cannot believe she let us do this every
Friday for about 18 months that just
sounds like literally the best thing
it was great it was but you know a large
when online gaming came out we all
thought this is it this is going to be
great we can have game night anytime
it's not the same and um the novelty
wore off pretty quick because part of
it's just being in a room and
experiencing something exciting and uh
twitch is as close as I've ever felt
because of the interactive nature of it
and the the reactions and
um though I probably do a better job of
taking the channel in a different
direction I love my game nights and I
love doing those things and luckily
there's enough people who who still like
that stuff yeah I mean you say you say
it's a Dying Breed but I think you know
there's a a massive Market of people who
just want that like kind of simple as
you said like game night feel right like
it's uh you know whether it's built on
Nostalgia just the fact that like it's
like you know some people don't go to
Twitch to like see these like
extravagant events they just want
someone to hang out with that's yeah
that's a really good point yeah but yeah
yeah I mean like a lot of twitch is just
you know being online a lot and just
kind of like being there to fill in like
hanging out yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like kind of like a friendship simulator
just hey just show up yeah there is a
nice element though for for me
personally where I I worked as a radio
DJ in America and I I did theater for a
long time and stuff and teaching to an
extent you do have that element of
performance time
and see if they hit or they did not and
uh yeah that to me is what keeps it
fresh and I am so thankful and humbled
that anybody even bothers to click that
so right it's a very it's a very
exciting thing to do I don't know man I
I tuned into your jumps jumping straight
and that was one of the funniest games
I've ever actually put I've never seen
someone who is playing a rage game where
they're meant to rage and just come out
of it so positively I'm like you are in
so many ways the most positive dude I've
met him yeah
like you'd fall down five screens and
you're like that's that's okay let's do
it again again that's no Oddball on you
know Halo with 16 people that you want
to kill you and like it's it's I've been
through some of those fires but yeah to
me I realized early on I remember on one
of my early streaming days I was playing
like a Spider-Man game and I I it was
the Miles Morales one and I didn't think
the game was it was good but I did it
was too much of the same for me yeah and
I was like yeah I had like eight people
in there and stuff and I remember this
guy was like I was kind of talking [__]
on the game saying like well you know I
think they've already I thought I felt
like I've done this same city same
things yeah and this guy was like I
never talk in this chat but I was so
excited to see this game and I was so
excited to see you play it and I and uh
you've just been so negative and I
thought to myself
well thanks for watching the stream
we're ending now um but like that
actually resonated because I have a
choice right how I approach these things
and I could be upset and I could be
negative but I think that it's more fun
to find the positive stuff in my in my
experience yeah my British cogs in my
brain oh yeah I totally get it but I
totally get it
that that really I was like you're right
I have a choice of what kind of content
that I I want to provide yeah so I'll
just keep I'll just keep doing and I
mean I do get angry occasionally but
like it's usually about my forehead size
or something oh you know they'll still
make fun of um the my physical
appearance but not in a bad way but like
you're like I was an oakamura Furniture
you know
I'm talking to El kante right now I'm
not gonna repeat to you yeah yeah
so yeah sometimes because you know we've
been on the internet for a long time we
uh have off how to have have had our
Fair show of like mean comments
everything like that so we're like
immune to a lot of it but sometimes you
just get that one comment I don't know
maybe you just like one thing you're
worrying about that one thing you are
really really worried about or insecure
about and it's it's happened to me like
live on Twitch and it's the worst When
It Happens live on Twitch because you
kind of like you go from instantly yeah
let's [__] do this stream to like I
just want to like end the stream yeah
right now and I don't know how to like
mask that first yeah for sure because
with a YouTube comment you're like [__]
it I'm I'm gonna be pissed for like an
hour go have like a nice meal or
something I'm gonna fight try and forget
it and then you wake up tomorrow like
all right let's do it we're on streaming
like [__] I'm I'm still up I'm still on
camera man
like smile through the pain smile
through the pain baby come on you can do
it sometimes you're streaming you're
like [__] I just for something for
whatever reason made you feel like [__]
maybe got a message that wasn't good
from someone who's like by the way your
house is burning down you know what I
mean like yeah occasionally you that's
why I tend to try and not check my phone
because sometimes you'll get a bad news
or something yeah something will get
canceled that you're looking forward to
and you're like well [__] my mood's kind
of ruined then now I gotta keep
streaming for two more hours at least
yeah I have to keep streaming for a
movie length and I sh and I'm not happy
yeah it's tough I'm pretty lucky I think
uh most people in this community I've
had has been so amazing and supportive
so I think like I I I I will get those
things but usually I'm like they're
right I I do need to exercise that's a
good point so I'll take that yeah you
yeah you use it as a like a vehicle to
kind of add humor to the stream it does
add a lot of elements and it does make
you kind of like almost indestructible
in a sense to to insults because it's
like all right well if you're gonna make
an insult and I'm able to play it off
and make an add to the content yeah yeah
well then it's like what what can you do
really yeah someone really wants to for
some reason upset you I don't know why
they would I know it's a weird thing but
you know you put yourself out there and
it's it's just uh it's part of the
territory that does come with it you get
all the feedback good and bad it can be
very rewarding instantaneously
instantaneously that's what twitch does
and I think that that kind of field
makes it so exciting for me but yeah I
did have can I ask one question really
quick because I I know that you guys do
get this one criticism occasionally that
sometimes on the anime podcast there's
no we don't talk about anime right
sometimes it's not a criticism not at
all I love it I've enjoyed it I just
wanted to I'm curious how I know how
anime started in America but I want to
know how you what was your guys's like
first exposure to animix I'm sure you've
told it before but I just haven't heard
it personally and I want to see how that
compares with like
1997-98 and the the horrors of what you
would have had to go through by lighting
anime when it started although I mean
like I would say because I've heard
stories about people who got it into
anime and like your era way it's kind of
like your era your era I can finally and
I can finally say that because normally
everyone I I look at like other content
creators and I'm just like you don't
know the pain
for me it was like it was part one out
of three espanol subtitle on YouTube
yeah on YouTube on YouTube yeah people
would like upload rips it would upload
because back then they had a 10 minute
uh like a 10 minute limit so they would
upload parts of the anime into threes
because it was obviously 24 minutes yeah
really yeah yeah and you can get a whole
anime series just uploaded on YouTube
unless unless it was like you find part
one but you can't find yeah but there's
part three yeah yeah that would happen a
lot yeah you'd have to just kind of be
like I just want to get through this
anime so I'm going to skip half this
episode and then that's a crucial detail
that's so crazy I mean yeah a lot of
people my age they go into anime through
like tsunami and yeah that'll swim that
was like a like Dragon Ball Z Gundam
Wing uh try Gun Cowboy
huge push yeah like in in terms of like
exposing people to anime and then the
internet era came on
um and that's when people started
discovering shows like Naruto and bleach
and one piece and that got a whole load
of other people into anime as well who
discovered anime through the internet
basically and but you paid the social
price back when the day when you had to
go to the video store or something like
that or Toonami what do you mean this uh
the social price like when there's
[__] anime liking anime yeah like oh
no I was a close anime fan
um yeah I I see in America like you
mentioned Toonami was the big one that
so like 98 99 2000 yeah and I remember
they showed some of Dragon Ball Z I
remember my friends ordered tapes like
VHS they paid like we saved up all of
our money and I was like I'm not gonna
contribute because I think this shit's
too dorky still but I I want to support
you guys I'll pay like the postage and
they got like they ordered it from Japan
and it was like 28 29 different VHS
tapes whatever and the worst quality
like you could not eat and there was no
subtitles yeah we were just watching the
cartoons and I was like you're watching
the pixels I was like this is lame and I
remember I was like nah I'm go I'm gonna
pivot here I'm not doing the Dragon Ball
thing I went to a family video we had in
Kansas City and they had like
the anime section was kind of off by
itself as it was and I was like no this
looks cool and I mentioned on a video I
did with you uh ninja scroll was the
first thing that I'd seen that came out
like 93 right ninja scroll is [__]
cool it's [__] awesome so I was like
wow this is amazing so then I got into
like record of lodos for Neon Genesis
yeah and I remember the dude was like
the guy working there was like hey man I
know you've been like checking out a lot
of the anime stuff you get like two
video games and like one anime I got
something to like blow your mind dude
and I was like let's [__] go he was
like all right normally like someone
your age can't actually go over there so
I'll just sneak it into like your bag
dude and I was like let's go and then uh
now this was unfortunate because when I
thought we were gonna watch something
kind of like I don't know like Vampire
Hunter D or whatever yeah yeah yeah uh
and my mom was like what are you
watching I like cartoons and I was like
yeah check it out this [__] was called
like shin Angel and it was like hardcore
hentai and I'm in my mind
I'm ashamed to say that I know Shining
you know actually that [__] started with
like pornography it like starts with
some vivid dream he's having and I was
like I think this is just the previous
job I was like this shit's weird the
whole time she was like oh dear this
isn't Disney and I was like no I was
like this is just some weird I don't
know what they do over you know I don't
know what's going on but like the
regular one the guy promised me it's
cool and she was like okay and I was
like but you don't have to watch you can
leave now and then it starts with Like A
Slice of Life School thing yeah and then
it's like this dude trying to like put
the subtitles or no if it was okay and
so I this one had something
this one was the VHS from the store the
ones we ordered were from a guy recorder
like International we waited like two
months during the summer to get a box of
tapes that also had like different
Japanese programs and commercials right
right yeah but Shan Angel didn't have
any of that and I was like and so we
made it about four minutes through that
thing and I hey silly I turned it off
and she was like I think he gave you the
wrong one and I was like yes he did that
guy is in big trouble you
go away and I'm going to make sure this
tape goes right back to him right
tomorrow morning and then I hid that
tape in my couch for like two years I
was like I'm never giving that back
because I don't wanna I was like one
it's kind of cool but two I don't want
to be the guy to be bringing back Shin
Angel to it Family Video
with my my anime I was like
that's enough I'm going back to games
this is what we do was it like so like
how popular was anime like at your era
was it like looked down upon were people
like bullies look down upon it was the
single worst thing you could do to your
social standing good I just I just
wanted to confirm D and D nerds were
like dude that is too much
you remind me like a story though I I
had like in University so we're having
like a boys line University
um
boys we're at the pub we had a few
drinks and we had like you know kind of
like a boys chat and uh the question got
uh someone posed the question what's
what's the most thing you've been
ashamed about jacking off to everyone's
like silent for a bit and then one of my
mate just goes
oh I jacked off to anime porn once and
everyone went oh [__] you actually did
that and here's me like silently sipping
on a plane being like
I'm not gonna say anything man you're
not gonna say anything
today yeah oh that's that's disgusting
man you you did that well the line was
blurred back then because uh anime and
nudity went hand in hand right because
there was some cool [__] that I remember
reading like gunsmith cats do you guys
know this yeah yeah like that was like a
cool thing to read Because or you know
the stories were really interesting yeah
but it always towed the line of decency
compared to like what everyone else was
into true and it wasn't really until you
Japan became kind of cool again like
around Battle Royale you know when that
started pushing things off in video
games but like anime not even until
College was that [__] allowed like you
if you liked anime you're also complicit
with liking hentai yeah well I mean
especially because like during like the
like especially like around the time
when you were getting into it like
around the world and I never got into it
I want to make that clearer
you know like around like the ninja
scroll era like the early 90s like that
was when like the 90s OVA boom was
around yeah that was during the time
where the anime industry was like No
Holds bar like nothing was off limits so
like you always had these shows that
were just like okay yeah it's just a
simple story of kids going to school
that's a lot of tits yeah and it's like
and there was no sign of that [__]
either and it just came like out of
nowhere well it was totally rampant
because there was some really cool anime
like even like Street Fighter 2 or the
King of Fighters or fatal Fury animes
yeah like those are really cool like
they were just these One-Shot kind of
like two-hour things but you still have
like Chun-Li taking a shower and like
that would never fly on like a Capcom
franchise today they'd you know I was
like it's such a weird like you had to
either hide it or or you know be that
guy it was like yes I like anime and
everyone's like dork and then you're
just like that's cool man you wouldn't
nerd that the Nerds would make fun of
yeah you would be yeah it's a tough one
but I do think it's neat because now I
have seen it come full circle like now
it's like you don't like anime you're a
little kids have it so [__] easy
today yeah man but I can't believe for
not liking it it's not fair man like you
don't like Demon Slayer okay or it's
like or it's kind of like a thing where
it's like you've only watched Naruto you
[__] know me like it's like bro well
there you have it I guess I'm glad I
dodged that particular bullet because I
was in the I was all in on gaming that
was all like that was all I cared about
and stuff but yeah that was it was a
death nail in Social and imagine talking
to any kind of dating opportunity zero
percent
you remind me of a ninja from the forest
the way you stealthily move through math
class
um I almost went further with that joke
and then I stopped but like that was the
it was it was too much it was just too
much but yeah I'm glad that I didn't
know about the YouTube 10 minute
I just remember that I I realized like
up until I was a teenager I'd just
pretty much never watched a full series
of anything because it was always
scattered on TV right you would never
you would never get to watch it in the
parts or in the order it was intended
and I kind of had this Revelation when I
was like oh my God this is so much
better when I can watch it in order and
all of it this is amazing I felt like
went on this like insane watching spree
where I didn't play any video games even
though I was addicted to video games I
would just spend all day watching like
Box series I was online because I was
just like oh my God you can watch things
in order wow for free that's kind of a
cool I mean I'm glad that that happened
because like my parents the only DVDs
they would ever buy was uh of the movies
and stuff so I only ever got to watch
movies in completion TV shows I often
never got to see where they went ever
right no yeah same here because when you
know in the era of TV
um like we couldn't like I couldn't
really afford DVDs way too much
especially
so you watch what you got on TV and that
didn't necessarily mean if you missed
the week then you just had to like deal
with the fact that you missed the week
you know and I think that's why you know
back when I was growing up I think
that's why Pokemon was so popular
because it has a storyline but you can
jump in most episodes and that's why
there's so much filler back then because
you know yeah you probably missed 10
episodes and yeah yeah I fear that for
me though
that ship has sailed I I feel I I've
tried to get into it because I know that
you guys are you you've talked about it
a lot and I know that a lot of the
people who I interact with now who like
Japan are interested in it she's an
angel like sports traumatized
whatever happened to it the copy I
actually think that somewhere in
Missouri if you lift up a certain panel
on the ceiling you'll find the actual
porn VHS that my friend splice together
from like Cinemax or yeah whatever and
he distributed it out to all the Buddies
back when we were 13 or something and
that shine Angel VHS one of your friends
sliced a porn video you don't know the
struggle at all I remember back in the
day you would he yeah so Cinemax or
skinamax is what we called it or HBO
none of us had subscriptions to this
because it was expensive but if you did
they would there was like he would make
it look nice or like the video would
start and it would be like Orion films
which had nothing to do with like the
porn stuff but he'd use like he'd record
that part from like a movie and then
he'd be like oh what are we getting
today this is gonna be exciting and then
that was the only porn you had for a
year that was it or if you I remember
when I was a kid I got a computer I got
like you know this this thing and it had
a printer and I I was like oh man I can
get like a picture of like Carmen
Electra naked or something and I was
like print and then it would be like
yeah I'd be like oh in three hours this
[__]
and then it would get like it'd be like
the sun you know and you see like a blue
sky and they didn't keep going and
you're like oh it's getting there and
then it'd be like Elmo from Sesame
Street like what the [__] I didn't
that's not what I downloaded and then it
was like not what you got yeah you use
like 22 of your ink from the uh that was
really expensive your mom's gonna kill
you well you know I boys will be boys
um but like and then we had the whole
era of of Kaza and LimeWire which is
um I thought I found your ninja actually
well well you could have just asked me
for Mike
I remember trying to like download like
a episode of something and I was like
this is this
this is a Naruto
it was always Shin angel or Bible black
that was that was the only two Choice it
was like specifically [__] Angel episode
two and it was only episode two that was
available on LimeWire I have no idea why
all right was that the one with the girl
who was jumping off the roof yeah oh
that's the one I watched it was fun when
you started describing I was like this
is bringing back a cool memory I've
completely forgotten I was never I was
never old enough or intelligent enough
to figure out how to use the computer at
the period when line while I was around
my brother was right brother was yeah
and I remember my brother getting
absolutely murdered by my parents
because he downloaded in just the most
so many viruses oh yeah it was basically
unusable yeah I just remember just my
dad just screaming at my brother and me
being like what's going on why is why is
Hillary Clinton uh why is Bill Clinton
talking yeah it's Bill Clinton
every time you'd get you'd search for
something oddly specific for example big
boobied woman threes yeah
random one yeah and then you'd get you'd
wait like two days yeah because it has
to be seated yeah yeah and then you'd
hit play and hit show Bill Clinton go I
did not have sex relations with that
woman that is legit the best troll
history
for Rick rolls yeah right so you'd be
like whoever whoever was the first guy
who came up with that literally the best
troll in the internet what a legend it
was awful and so you and then I remember
reformatting your PC was a regular thing
you'd have a friend who knows how to do
it yeah and we'd be like I heard Windows
98 version two is way better than
Windows XP and you'd be like let's
[__] do that then let's get a cracked
version of this and then we'll do that
and it was like that's why when you say
I didn't grow up with the internet era I
feel like I you know that was the
beginning yeah yeah for sure like I
think what separates that in my mind
because when I was growing up it was
sort of like this where it was like
there was this there was this moment
when you were done with the computer and
you logged off oh yeah and then it was
it was it yeah yeah whereas now it's
like you are always online yeah and so
in my mind that's where like the notable
switch is is like when it was more
accessible in your phone and every app
was on there and you know now it
suddenly became where you used to have
to log on to MSN or log on to these chat
rooms to try and chat now it's like oh
you can reach me anytime yeah that's
where I felt like the internet became
what it is today yeah and before that
was kind of the wild west where it was
like Hey if you're online we chatted if
you if you weren't whatever you're like
AOL Instant Messenger what's the big one
and it even had like the door opening
sound when you'd have a list of all the
contacts like you said and it'd be like
you you just message them well you they
usually had an away message app or they
it would be like they wouldn't be on the
online list so but you hear that and
then you would you'd be like oh who was
that that just logged in right oh cool
and then you'd talk to them for two or
three hours yeah but then they'd be like
I gotta go and be like and you're like
well okay and you could customize the
sounds and yeah man that was um that was
some fun stuff but I think that we're in
a nice place now where now there's a
platform for everybody to do what any
anything and everything that they've
ever wanted so that's pretty cool good
or bad that's good all that yeah it's
it's it's uh there's a good points and
those bad points to be connected all the
time you know I mean I feel like now
there was a big separation between what
you did online and what you did outside
of the internet and now that sep that
that war is just getting like thinner
and thinner every year serial
experiments Lane said that [__] like 20
years ago and they were right they were
[__] right no [__] right yeah but
I did bring uh one small thing just so
and we're gonna put it at the very
bottom of all this mess it's got a shin
Angel toy I swear oh God damn it I I
couldn't get it this is this is my hat
I'll wear in a second I guess but I feel
like the real anime that never gets
talked about is is my guys from Ninja
Turtles so I'm going to leave that down
near the bottom so that there's some
American representation
we have LeBron James
LeBron James another another
representation okay look we have LeBron
James all right get that back we'll put
that near the bottom near that banana oh
look you can keep
up but yeah that's then
that's a cool toy Richard Mike Wazowski
but I was like that's that's Pixar it's
not anime or it's not animation cartoons
are different you know so you go so I
felt like you needed something because I
don't understand any of what's Happening
Here and honestly this is giving me soon
would you like to know would you like to
know does this invoke ah besides the
thing I watched with my mother this
looks like see this looks like some
Naruto [__] I don't know that [__]
she looks like the hidden ninjas like
welcome to the end and I'll serve you up
a pork tonight or whatever you poor
naive child and then you've got the the
one in the Middle with the spear yeah
that's like some hardcore you know
oh it's a katana yes that's like a the
nodachi it's like the big one yeah man
let me tell you about fake Pete oh
that's fate that's where they have uh uh
a God that's not funny you'd be
surprised this is this is fake oh God
wait this is fate this is funny oh [__]
yeah that other one is also yeah you
just picked up picked up two fake well
sweet Grand order of the Marshalls or
whatever
I know this [__] it's like you could
have stopped at Grand yeah
what's the full name again fake Grand
order xr2 uh this time it's serious but
like I know because it's a regular
person and then they'll have like Athena
or some historical person like Abraham
Lincoln or some [__] yeah
cute anime girl right yeah I didn't know
that they were sitting on them like
historical yeah the King Arthur is like
a like a hot chick oh wait you see that
character over there this one that's
King Arthur that's King Arthur like I
thought that was I thought
she's not the girl who knows King Arthur
King Arthur yeah
it's like Genghis Khan or something
Nebraska okay all right well so you know
I I'm not familiar with all of it but
like and the one I do like because I I
do have a dark history with hooked on
okay
that's the best one dude I love Pachinko
won so much money playing Pachinko it's
not even funny when I first came to
visit did you learn from the guy
it was the the host family I came on New
Years and the dad or it was her uncle he
said like here's some uh the New Years
money I was like I'm 22 and he's like
it's cool man because you're it's
usually for kids yeah right and uh he
took me to Pachinko and I was playing
some kurohige pom-poms pirate [__] and
it's like that yeah and I won like eight
hundred dollars
I felt so bad because I kept winning and
they kept losing money but they couldn't
leave because my chain bonus was out of
control so they're just sitting there
next to me they're like have you lost
yet and I'm like no man it keeps saying
dokan I don't know what's going on what
is it's like explaining well and so I
won all this money and I was I was able
to get a a PlayStation 3 that was like
the White Version
because if you trade your balls for an
item yeah or for like
pieces of plastic that somehow someone
next door really wants to buy right and
then you you'll be like I'll trade you
this piece of plastic for like 200 she's
like okay and that's because it's
illegal to gamble yeah the loophole is
crazy so I was able to buy everyone like
dinner and I was like when I come back
to Japan I'm playing Pachinko again and
I started playing hooked on okin and I
had no [__] clue who was who cares
Raul or whatever I thought he was like
the best dude ever because he was so
strong
and I hated that joggy guy but I love
seeing him because he's the easiest to
win off of and like I knew of joggy I
knew every single element of these games
and I I've played every kid machine
that's ever come out yeah and uh Kyojin
no Hoshi it's a baseball manga from like
the Edo period yeah I can't say it right
but those two games I still yearly go on
my pilgrimage with like 200 bucks and I
either Break Even or I rake in some cash
anyway so have you actually watched or
red hooked on again uh I know
he knows he knows I know the songs I
know idle you know you are sure you know
you are shocked uh welcome to this crazy
oh my God I know all that [__] and I
know uh
and I used to make mistakes because when
Ken would show up on the screen if he
was doing something he'd go like yeah I
didn't know what that meant but it
sounded cold-blooded so I'd say that's
like teachers in my way and that means
like get the [__] out of here get the
[__] out of the way yeah and they would
be like is he almost hit it and I'd be
like okay which is like remove yourself
sometimes uh this I remember I was like
this is why you shouldn't learn Japanese
from anime this was the worst example
though because I was teaching at the
first school I was teaching these
elementary school kids oh man it's so
bad this is so bad and these kids were
like seven or eight and we were playing
dodgeball and I had to be on like the
loser kid team and I was like I'm not
gonna lose to a bunch of and this one
kid kept talking [__] from across the
arena right and I was like okay okay
okay all right and every time he threw
it I would like you know catch the ball
and I'd be like you're out and then he
was like Baka and I was like now wait a
minute I'm a teacher son you know I was
like so I I felt really bad I didn't
throw it hard
that hard but I threw it and I uh he
ducked and I hit another kid in the face
who was not looking right and I remember
like we kept playing and then I finally
got the kid out and I was like quiero
it's like disappeared
disappear it's like I you will never be
reincarnated it's like your body is gone
forever and I remember I was and the kid
was like he thought that was really
funny so he we know I thought we
connected yeah and I felt bad for the
kid I bought him like an ice cream or
something else yeah sorry kid he was
fine but then the the gym teacher came
back and he he looked very flustered and
he wrote on like a little Post-It note
he must have been like scribbling
looking it up he was like these are
children please don't throw hard I was
like I'm so sorry but I was like he was
calling me vodka whatever
I [__] got him
all these you know right that was my
second week in Japan and so I'd already
been going through some phases where
kids like the Concho phase was very
popular where they where they do this
thing to teachers yeah yeah that was
really popular in the countryside so
like I said you had to make our own fun
now yeah you may think you're teaching
but overall you're more of an ambassador
and you're you're almost like a student
with the kids and a lot of the times
right you play the same games you you
eat the same lunches and you hear the
same jokes and obviously I learned very
quickly don't use phrases it would have
been absolutely legendary if you had
like cultable and you'd be like
so bad I didn't say that I'm so glad I
think piano is pretty bad though oh yeah
luckily the kid took it as a joke so as
well you got to use
I think I actually learned that from
like an RPG game because I always I'm a
subtitled dub I'm not dub guy right I
like yeah yeah
it was it was it was pretty enlightening
and I must say the other nine and a half
ten years I I was a very good person I
didn't take take it out throwing
dodgeballs at kids but yeah
eviscerated children hey man you can
only take so much physical abuse before
you're like look okay all right we're
all playing yeah
I play too you know you're pretty big
you are stronger than me all right so
but yeah it was it was a good experience
and I it's kind of funny the the kid who
I said that to and uh some of those some
of those that that class yeah wrote me a
letter like three years ago saying that
they had finished like junior high
school or something yeah and that they
missed they missed uh Peterson say or
whatever so that sucks a lot yeah one
class
that school yeah do you remember that
one teacher
good kids good kids good experiences but
yeah that's hooked and okay I do know
kinshido so like yeah hey wait is that
the the butler guy pouring drinks is
that you yeah well it's not me but
that's you I mean I mean a lot of girls
believed it for a while yeah just a
character I did a lot of impersonations
of on YouTube yeah and is that Snow
White on the other side that's uh one
piece that's one piece that is one piece
yeah yeah it's not the one piece it's
the character no I know I know Snow
White from the angle I saw it it looked
Vaguely Familiar that's Nico Robin
That's Nico Robin yeah she's a navigator
or something right okay
actually yeah she's the
archaeologists yeah this is awesome yeah
what the [__] is that the boxer Joe guy
nope
that's gone from Hunter Hunter oh dear
this is just a mess
um yeah this is a bit illicit I think
because we can't show that I think
direct close-ups uh I know this because
it's a video game so near is cool yeah
it's cool and I feel like anime here's
the thing I'll say and why I I grew up
reading comic books right yeah comic
books are cool and they have some
awesome stories yeah but the reading
slam dunk when I was in nigata for like
because uh I had nothing to do yeah I
was like crying at the end of that story
legendary
oh absolutely so good and I think what I
really respect about Manga and Anime is
they're not afraid to take risks with
their characters that American Comics
are like they'll kill people they will
do tragic stories and most importantly
their stories except for one piece and
the fact that you have these cool
stories it's not like Spider-Man's back
for issue
1267. yeah and so all the characters
who've died and been around I like that
they have these single consequences
there's consequences I love how you I
love how you say that they end when you
read the one manga but you know wait
that's actually yeah well he wrote
Vagabond too right yeah he also wrote
real as well which is the wheelchair
basketball that hasn't ended either well
all right take all of it back yeah man
manga [__] man he's only finished
slamming well I think there are other
stories like I bet fake Grand designs or
whatever ended right
Santa and fate uh yes see that's cool
kinda kinda kinda it's Santa and face
he's kinda see it depends on like it
depends
yeah you know well I I think it's it's
something maybe I'll leave to The
Experts then and I'll stick with my
teaching and stuff well uh you know I
would love to just keep checking with
you beautiful like you just have like a
wealth of stories like this is like for
those of you who like tuning in to
people the first time this is like a
tiny [__] corner of the stories that
Pete has like a drop in the bucket and
uh if you want to hear more stories
check out history yeah check out yeah
where can they find you Pete no you know
I it doesn't matter
to go check him out thanks but I just
want to say it was really awesome being
a part of this and sharing these these
stories with you guys and like uh it was
very humbling thank you it was I had
lived some of the most insane
experiences of my life again and uh I
hope that's that chapters because thank
you guys so much for letting me be here
yeah absolutely so much and again guys
in your stories yeah and again guys
please go check out Pierce I know he's
not gonna do it but we'll do a thing in
the description check him out he's
[__] awesome but uh Hey look all
these patrons though you see all these
patrons on screen yeah wow everywhere
look at them who's your favorite not
that one the one right down there right
after you've seen Shin Angel which one
which one of these I've seen which one
hasn't seen Shin angel I feel like
probably all of them
I know the patreons
I know but no that is that is pretty
epic and maybe I should join as well
this patreon community not a shin Angel
veteran I have wisdom to provide so well
I'll tell you exactly what you can do it
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you had our face listen
to us on Spotify but uh yeah thank you
let's go
thank you so much and uh hopefully you
guys enjoyed it we'll see you next week
bye
[Music]